when i don't see him for a few days he
gets on the weekends i lose him thursday
night
he rubs feet he takes orders and he gets
a bit slapped and i lose him and then
thanks somebody said that to me on
twitter then i got to [ __ ] feed him
all this [ __ ] to bring him back in and
then he's good till wednesday i get on a
plane and i come back on monday and he's
[ __ ] half a harvey homo again what's
going on with you are you a little
purple shirt you're looking good that's
a beautiful shirt thank you i got it
it's actually i got my first sponsor for
flying to your radio so thank you look
at you with the stars
yeah they're from australia australians
are some cool [ __ ] i've never met an
australian i didn't like really
seriously they're really
something
i don't know what it is they're nice
they're just nice and you know when you
at the comedy store late night anytime
after like one o'clock especially like
during the week because their vacations
are like two months long they go on
holiday and they just like travel around
the world for like two months if it's
late night and there's five people left
in the or at the store three of them
australians all of them yeah
because the time difference it's like
noon to them and australians can drink
till the [ __ ] cows come home
they're indestructible
no the guy was very he just hit me up so
i mean it's a great company but it's uh
i've never been there i've never done
that kind of the longest flight i ever
did was like i think 14 hours have you
ever been to australia no but that's a
hell of a flight that's like 18 hours or
some [ __ ] that's crazy for all the
people who listen to the podcast i got
to get something off my chest i just got
found out this morning
i always knew
i wasn't going to be eligible to get a
passport i've only been lying to you
guys for a long [ __ ] time
i told my wife today i said listen
because we got the letter back
which i knew
the [ __ ] names don't match up
my father's name on the
on my birth certificate
and on his cuban birth certificate don't
add up they made a mistake in new york
they made like six mistakes in new york
right but the the truth of the story is
that i was born in cuba but when they
got citizenship or whatever they gave me
a new york city birth certificate
and they gave me that birth certificate
and i remember having the original my
mother died it was a black
piece of paper that had been typed and
they shrunk it down in those days and
that's what you took home it was stamped
it was
everything was on it
and it had like my dad was a waiter
you know like [ __ ] like that on it which
was always rare i lost that birth
certificate i applied for a new one then
they sent me this complete different
[ __ ] sheet of paper right like like a
diploma it looks like a high school
[ __ ] diploma yeah and once i got that
high school diploma i looked at it i
looked at the names and i basically
folded it up in my pocket and prayed for
the best
when i went to jamaica i sweated it the
first time i went to jamaica i sweated i
went to hawaii i sweated it that's
america though i always i was still
anytime you fly over the ocean you get
dicey
you know i know for a fact i went to
venezuela as a kid
either i have a passport or something
happen but i will tell you that
nothing's going to add up
and like i told terry i have a friend
that's 40 a cuban girl in colorado yeah
[ __ ] chick's been here since she was
three well guess what she got a letter
about [ __ ] six months ago she's not a
us citizen
something happened the computers this
[ __ ] gotta start from scratch and in
the meantime she can't get a job
ugh it's it's so that's what i [ __ ]
need that's what i [ __ ] need right
now to send in for this passport and for
them to find some [ __ ] up and next thing
you know i'm getting arrested and
getting deported because if there's
anybody they're going to [ __ ] deport
i talk about obama's wife i want to eat
her [ __ ] he writes this [ __ ] down and
he's like i'll keep that [ __ ]
mind
jesus that's good so 40 years later
she's now finding out that's what
unbelievable you know so what can she do
is she just [ __ ] i talked to her when
i was in denver she came to the shows
with her son and the husband you know
i've known him for 20 [ __ ] years
so i never wanted to mess with it like
i'm very lucky i'm very fortunate i'm
one of those guys once i know i'm very
fortunate i'm living in the best country
in the world and yeah i don't get to
travel to other countries to do comedy
and people like you're losing money
listen i know for a fact that if i apply
and push the [ __ ] envelope like this
attorney called today he's like this is
not what's going on i explained that you
know this is new york 1966. they did
everything by [ __ ] hand yeah yeah you
know some of that stuff like i went
looking for records seven years ago in
union city and they sent me to a library
to do the [ __ ] thing where you have
the sheet and you got to put it under
the microscope
microphone yeah and they have it on
computer i didn't know what i was doing
so i just abandoned [ __ ] i ran the [ __ ]
out of there you look at that news yeah
that [ __ ] under [ __ ] 1985 now
under 19
79 80 your shit's gonna cuz then my
police record half of it is gone
half of it is gone i just got my record
two years ago when i got my criminal
when they stole my identity and i just
got my police from me and terry were
talking let's go see through it and i
told like oh there's
15 arrests that are completely missing
we call the service and no this is
what's on there they had a i had a two
false arrests that were not me
you know two jose diaz is that one you
know my name is jose diaz
what the [ __ ] that's uh john smith yeah
the united states
go to miami and look for jose diaz
you're dying
you'll be there for [ __ ] you know two
years oh yeah that's why i always knew i
just go to miami they'll never find me
right the yellow pages diaz is eight
nine 10 15 [ __ ] pages in miami mm-hmm
but do you like does it worry you like
are you sitting there nervous yeah i was
always worried i've always been worried
because my parents fooled the pulled a
quick one
they pulled the quick one my wife went
on uh ancestry ancestry.com yeah right
my uncle's on there
my dad's on there my mom
she ain't on it this [ __ ] went lived on
the whatever islands the cuckoos islands
outside of cuba she lived in venezuela
she lived in chile
she's not on there no ellis island
record of dinorah [ __ ] valdez tuero
malvarez nothing all the names she's
involved with
you know so it's these people pulled a
quick one it was the [ __ ] 50s and 60s
you went to miami the way you used to be
used to go to mexico yeah you know
we went to miami the way to cuba i'm
sorry the way today you go to las vegas
it was easier in 1955 to go to cuba than
what it is to fly from here
to
vegas yeah you know you you go through
less drama in the 50s going to cuba wow
it's like a 30-minute flight yeah it was
me you were hanging out with well it's
like 90 miles so it's going to be like a
10 minutes miami so you're in new york
city listen
in the [ __ ] 84
i left new york for different reasons
but i got to be honest i left new york
because i wouldn't have lived
in 1984 thibault
there was an airline called people's
express already sounds dangerous okay
people's express offered flights to
three places you ready
newark to miami
newark to london and newark to los
angeles that's it here's the catch
you never call them up you couldn't call
them up and go hi this is lee syed i
want to come get on people's express
that did not work for them here's how it
worked you showed up
you showed up and if you're you came up
and got on that plane before so
you show the airport and you go how you
doing my name is jason t but i want to
go to london
mr tebow i don't even think you had to
have id in those days yeah it was
ridiculous
they didn't know there was no id
okay
they give you a receipt and you paid on
the plane
it's like a [ __ ]
like a like a but like a shuttle bus
right right on the plane and then they
came up and they told you what it was
for a blanket it was six dollars oh it's
experience for a snack box it was six
bucks for a pillow it was two for
earphones with music it was five so by
the time you got off
you paid
eighty dollars in extras yeah you know
the luggage was 15. you know the flight
was but you know you're dealing with
uncle joey yeah i would go see joe the
bacon the bronx in those days and get 10
credit cards matching ids and an
insurance card and a mass card for a
nickel right do you know how much wear
and tear i got out of those stolen
credit cards so you get on the plane and
i get on that plane and start buying
drinks for [ __ ] yeah i was nuts in
those days give that sexy [ __ ] a
drink give her a drink give her a drink
and they could take they could take
credit cards on the plane they only took
credit cards on the plane so what they
did in those days it wasn't did they
think they did it
the imprint you could let that slide off
yeah that's like [ __ ] stealing like
nothing i know you don't know how many
chinese lunches because under 25 hours
they didn't check the book okay what's
the book there was okay so here's what
it's like young i don't know what this
let's talk about all right the book was
that if you went they were i was called
an under the limit thief
the limit on credit cards in those days
that they had a call to them was 50
bucks so if you went to a store and
spent 42
they just imprinted it
so but if you spend 50 they had to call
the company
i called in they do the
imprint and call in i have jason tebow
three three four five six expiration six
twenty six six two sixty four dollars is
approved okay but if you didn't spend
over 50 they're busy you go to a busy
store they want to take the time so this
is part of the whole scam you went to a
busy store so you watched you went to
the mall you watched the ladies who was
the busiest and you brought the thing
42.
yeah it was like stealing so i used to
have lunch every day
in those days we always went to lunch
because we pick a chinese lunch special
me and you even if it was 5.95 it's on
us
we'll all sign all those spare ribs a
couple cokes you know i'm saying so we
became under the limit thieves
that's what that call it's the scummiest
people in the world but i had a great
time happens to me like every six months
i think one of the post offices has a
guy in there scanning the cards because
every card i get from bank of america
gets i didn't even uh activate this one
i didn't even activate it and they had
it yeah that means they got it from the
other side and they go to like ross and
they spend five dollars and they eat and
but then they go and find try to find
one big one once they find out that it's
active then they go to find one big one
that's what the guy said let me tell you
what howard jason jason tebow so you
meet a [ __ ] in new york city okay all
right i already like the story okay you
get out of work at one
okay one
one in the morning you're walking out of
your little bartending union job with
your little black vest
but while you're there some [ __ ] some
chick from australia is talking to you
right i really like to go out and
drink you
for what you thought i might even have a
drink you have two drinks and the chick
starts telling you how life um you know
she she she does blow three times but
she really doesn't like it look hook you
make the call right there hold on baby
listen bring me a gebo i got a live one
yeah right
you start giving this chick bump she's
on she sucks your [ __ ] dick
all right one in the morning in those
days 3 30. tebow i swear to my [ __ ]
daughter and wife three in the morning i
can look at you and go deep
i got an eight ball i got like 600 what
do you got i got 800.
let's get the [ __ ] let's go to miami
we take a cab to newark airport for 20
bucks they ran on the hour on the top of
the hour people's express they knew the
drug addiction they were the drug plan
how many hours a day
24 hours
here's where it gets interesting
here's where it gets interesting from
eight
to midnight it was 69 dollars
but for me tonight to eight in the
morning it was 39 one way
so come on guys i'm lying to you in
those days yeah 40 bucks down it didn't
matter we were putting it on the chinks
credit card from brooklyn bob
it's under a 50. so they're not going to
check
they're going to go ching ching and then
when they land they're going to run it
it's a fake car done and it's already
there and we're going on there drinking
champagne oh yeah we're going that's
crazy i did that to boston to new york
yeah 30 40 bucks on a bus but you flew
to miami miami in those days and then
you waited down there for three days
till your money was spent yeah in those
days the whole every listen miami knew
what you were going down there for sure
basically all those 80s and especially
those dingy uh
dirtier ones those motel sixes they
dropped their price for 15 because all
the drug deals in the world were being
cut in those [ __ ] hotel rooms yeah i
mean it was crazy you get on those plans
i remember getting on the plane and i
swear to god guys let's say there was
90 seats let's pretend
60 of those seats
8
55 of those people will have it oh yeah
habit i mean [ __ ] dripping down their
nose how much was la do you remember
i think it was like 99
one way no no no i'm lying to you guys
it was really cheap that's what the law
was there was but sometimes you showed
up and there was a line and you had to
stay there all day
because now you had to qualify for the
next flight so sometimes you get to that
terminal and there'd be four thousand
people out there not on the midnight to
miami those were only coke fiends
vampires and people with eggs zombies
looking for new blood [ __ ] those are the
people that were chasing mel giving
people that were chasing mad max and
[ __ ] those pale [ __ ] with the
blood too yeah it was you should have
seen this plane people it was
it was just a flying party and this is
what
like this is why i didn't really after i
left that scene in 85
i knew i would never match that like i
had mingled in colorado and i had i went
to aspen and aspen was a cocaine capital
and you know the party i
i had lived through and it was rich
cocaine party rich when i was a kid
there was a party a pool a place called
patty bugatti's and it was a bar with a
pool in the middle so after a few drinks
you could jump in the [ __ ] pool this
is craziness yeah and i went there a
couple times and women would jump in the
pool and next thing you know they'd take
their bottoms off and you'd be [ __ ]
on my finger in the pool this is some
great this is and yeah those were
different types of things that i had
seen i don't think i don't think i
fingered someone i just heard stories
but
when i left
something like when i left new york the
[ __ ] i saw in those clubs like i was
never a club guy but to me that the
nights i did go out like with my friend
mike ask at least one night we went out
with like an ounce of blow one night to
those boom boom boom clubs we're in bat
women's bathroom snorting with six
people in the stall
you know and that's fun but that's why
when i left but that [ __ ] flight
i wish i would have had a camera to show
you people even the stewardesses were
hammered i was gonna ask what they were
doing even the stewardesses were
happening and that's you could probably
still smoke on a plane back then smoke
on the plane and i remember there was a
plane that i used to take united
from san francisco to new york that was
a double decker and in those days the
bottom was regular class and they
treated you like a human being but the
top of the plane was first class you
know there used to be double decker
planes yeah in midnight express when
they're going coast to coast that's
where the planes were miami new york
miami la la new york it was double
decker planes you go upstairs i swear to
god there would be i'm gonna forget that
there was a [ __ ] pig one time
and people were picking off the [ __ ]
pig like jesus like [ __ ] with an
apple in his mouth with hors d'oeuvres
around it that's the time t-ball but i
went up to first class i bought a
first-class ticket on the united i
thought i was a gangster i was bringing
back guns
and i was wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait i was taking guns from colorado to
jersey
and two hours later getting on the same
flight going back to denver and then i
would have a connection from denver to
[ __ ] aspen but i would leave that i
would take like the six a.m on aspen
connecting in denver 805 and i'd be in
ella and new jersey at 11 and i'd be at
the two o'clock flight from newark right
back to the we were selling guns and i
was taking the guns back and bringing
the coke so i wasn't trading guns for
coke trading guns for cokes old school
old school
jesus with the miami vice holster like i
would say
listen to me if you when i would put the
miami i would get there and danny
biancolo and like three of his spanish
friends would be sitting on a couch and
i would be their model
and i'd put the miami vice holster on
the don johnson with the [ __ ] gun
this way uh-huh and the two clips here
and i would just sit there i was like a
walking ebay i'd say make an offer
where would you sit i'd stand and they'd
be like on couches and i'd take through
the whole thing put the gun in the clip
clip it put it here but in like a house
in his apartment jesus and his apartment
well that's danny next time i'm gonna
sell how many guns would you ha would
you take eight guns
and i'd pay
i got the guy down to 500 and he'd throw
in a box of bullets and of the holsters
the hostesses were retail 100 and some i
think i was wholesaling eight of them at
60 apiece or something yeah so my whole
cost the guns was 450. i think my whole
cost on everything was maybe like six
and i would charge 11. okay and then i
would take eight guns because it was a
it would be 8 800 that's a quarter of a
kilo
okay so i would pick up 11 ounces for 8
000
and bring it back that was my usual
wild tremendous tremendous that had to
be like an adrenaline dump too and i get
on those flights [ __ ] lit
this is why i should be doing 20 [ __ ]
years and i'll never forget that one
time they were playing the piano on this
thing they had the pig on the table and
i'm in first class hammered yeah just
hammered it'd been three days t-shirt
sure you know deep this is when i had a
cocaine endurance been there the heart
didn't even bother me if it pumped that
meant that i was alive yeah yeah yeah
and i [ __ ] went up to a thing and it
was a black velvety thing and i'm over
there with the bartender give me another
one i'm [ __ ] banging them 20s the
guy's looking at me like oh my god this
guy's a savage
and i kept going to the back and doing
bumps and coming back and one of those
there was a black tablecloth
and i'm like this and all of a sudden i
felt it tebow i felt it was stuck up
here and it's i could feel it getting
loose but i couldn't cover it there was
people at the table that's the worst and
the bartender was looking at me and all
of a sudden the coke rock just fell
and it hit the [ __ ] thing and
everybody looked at the same time
and everybody looked at me and i looked
at them and i looked to the top
like
where did this coke fall from it wasn't
my nose it was [ __ ] plain and i just
left and went downstairs and never went
back upstairs the rest of the flight so
you pay for a first class flight coke
falls out of your nose and then you go
down sit with the common folk after that
because you could mingle in those days
see that's the worst those days you can
mingle you can mingle you can walk
around with a drink and go hey where are
you from smoke you could you could smoke
there's like a giant flying scene
in the back you could smoke in the back
you could smoke and then first class you
could smoke
so you could mingle
you know in those days a flight was a
party it wasn't people sitting like this
together like yeah when you walk in the
[ __ ] coach they're like this that's
what you look like it's a punishment to
fly the punishment to fly so in those
days people were more loose it was two
seats
you know they had different types of
food they had sandwiches they used to
have creams and colognes in the bed and
the bathrooms so when you go in there
you want to put cream on your hands or
cologne they had little bottles they
don't [ __ ] around dog they took all that
away but my point
to that people's express
how crazy is that like that i remember
doing that like four weekends in a row
in september of 84. i mean it's cheaper
than and then i was doing it like i did
it again there was two kids from our
high school that were down there selling
and moving around
and i was trying to nail one of those
kids and i kept going down and i found
myself i'm going
i can't live like this this is a hundred
dollars to get [ __ ] up this is eighty
dollars because it's forty and forty
four what you do now is when you go back
you go back after midnight yeah that's
it you just sleep all day and go to the
airport eleven and pray for a twelve or
one o'clock flight do you ever rob
people on the plane because that seems
like you could go back and forth and
just like rob people if it was a party
that's interesting you said that
of course he did i got stuck one time
when i was when i first met my
daughter's mother her she was a criminal
me and her were [ __ ] criminals your
ex-wife my ex-wife
and we had robbed we were we were
setting up the building i was robbing a
bookie in this hotel i lived at the
virginian hotel
downtown san francisco on the tenderloin
it's still there it's a hostel now oh
it's just up there across from the
hilton and down the corner they used to
be fat ron's coffee shop
they'd be topless coffee waitresses this
was the tenderloin was a crazy time and
i moved in there i was on the run from
colorado for credit cards
and i lived in the virginia and i nailed
them i loved dressing up and i'd go to
the hilton and all the hotel california
all those and i'd sit in the lobby with
a newspaper and i'd watch the mates and
i'd follow the maids and i'd steal their
keys now i had two or three days no i
didn't i wasn't a kid with an earring or
a tattoo
i looked pretty i was built in those
days and i dressed nice so
and i had a nice smile like unassuming
people unassuming and i was i was i was
an outsider i was from new york so they
didn't [ __ ] know but i was a [ __ ]
24-hour thief
and the cops caught up with me one time
and we had to take a bus to reno and
then we went back we had a pawn all the
jewelry we robbed and we don't have
enough for one plane to take out of
something i don't know what the [ __ ] the
deal was so i put her on the plane
and she goes let me go to boulder give
me a couple days and i'll get the money
i was at a [ __ ] airport guys for
three [ __ ] days that was the airport
where i went to piss in those days you
go to the airport
like if you have nothing to do we could
in those days there wasn't no buzzers
you could walk your family all the way
to the plane in those days so oh you
want me to the airport in those days
people would drop you off like an animal
they would park have a drink with you
and walk you to the [ __ ] gate and
wave at you as your plane went away but
then with their kids absolutely it was a
complete different [ __ ] world
so people would walk into the airport
just to drive a drink and that was the
place in 85 it was 85 where i kept going
to the bathroom
and it was the same dude in there and
what he'd do you'd piss and he'd be in
one store urinal and he'd go to the
other urinals get next to lee and try to
look at his dick and i think he'd jerk
off and then once lee would leave he'd
sit there and make believe he was pissed
and then you come in and he'd go to your
urinal
next to you and he'd look at your dick
and i went into this the first time i'm
like this [ __ ] guy but i didn't say
nothing the second time i went in he
popped right he was sweating and [ __ ]
how old was he like describing him i had
to be maybe
22 and this guy was probably 30
something but you could see he was up
for a few days yeah sweating this is
what he does all day every day yeah he
probably just did that all day every day
just go to bathrooms and look at a guy's
dick what a terrible life
so what did you say to him
get the [ __ ] away from me in those days
i had no tolerance for that stuff like i
didn't understand that i was out of new
york i was still a little [ __ ] up i
carried a weapon
so i always carried a weapon in those
days so i just don't get the [ __ ] away
from me i don't know if i had a weapon
on me that day or not but that's when i
carried a weapon 85 in san francisco i
carried a weapon
i always had something mommy because
that's a scary [ __ ] time
but especially back then
it's not that scary now there's some
shitty parts but nintendome still has
his moments lee was up there he says
i mean it was there were some parts that
like weren't great but then like we were
reading reviews for our hotel and
they're like it's scary
it's not scary you just don't don't be
stupid
but it was you've told me about that i
can't believe they have topless coffee
bar that seems crazy fat runs or
something ron's coffee house and it was
open 24 hours that way i think you could
put booze in the coffee yeah
they were topless
top baristas or whatever they had like
girls that were regular bartenders and
they had topless [ __ ] uh
you could bring your own booze or they
would actually throw blues in there on
the dlc they threw booze in there i
never i'm not at that time i didn't
drink [ __ ] coffee i drank a coke and
a butter roll for breakfast yeah and i
was ready to go there was no cereal
there was no oatmeal there was no apple
right it was a butter roll and a [ __ ]
can of coke dog and a joint [ __ ] it with
a straw
coke with a straw the carbonation would
[ __ ] rattle your head in those days
uh-huh
absolutely so what's been going on
brother talk to me uh not much man i
actually look just me and sam tripler
just in san francisco and then i was in
the midwest for
five months before that
getting clean quit drinking again quit
doing drugs again
you know i mean i never i
truly always joke she's like dude you
don't you never had a drug problem
really i would do coke
absolutely i'd smoke pot 24 7. i don't
count pot as [ __ ] pop but you know if
you have a problem with pot you have
deeper [ __ ] you're just a [ __ ] or
something you know what i mean like
something's wrong with you if pot's
making your life crazy
uh but you know i would do coke just to
[ __ ] sober back up and keep drinking
but triple is always like dude you're
you're like a 1945 drinker you know what
i mean like you that's like your past
life was like
like mad men and [ __ ] you know what i
mean i was what did you drink towards
the end what were you drinking i mean i
you know
it's hard to tell i mean but would you
start at nine would you i would start i
mean if i was if i was if i was tying it
on for the day i'd probably start around
11 a.m
you know i'd probably have
six to eight beers
jack and coke or two and then go out
you know don't nap
no no no [ __ ] no were you hung over from
the day before
not really this i don't i never really
got hung over which is a dangerous thing
you know like he's just because we
didn't get that hung over i was never
the guy like drinking's never been my
thing
but like if i was gonna go i'd get drunk
but then i could never understand going
out thursday through saturday even just
that was crazy to me because how you
feel like i felt like [ __ ] the next day
that's just because you're not a drinker
right well i never got like hungover
hungover
but like a couple times but normally
it's just like it takes out of you like
yeah i always woke up at six a.m after
being after going to bed at two like it
was just it's a it's a heart it's like a
really taxing
like like alcohol attack that makes you
tired the next day at least for me it
takes a lot of recovery from the sugar
how old were you when you had your first
drink uh i didn't start drinking until
late i was like 19. did you consider
yourself an alcoholic at the time you
yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah but i mean even then
like even when i was 19 i was like i am
there was a part in my
[ __ ] soul or head or some [ __ ] that
was like i am going to have a problem
with this
you know both my my father was an
alcoholic both sets my grand
grandparents were big drinkers
you know they were from that kind of
like sinatra era of their you know it
was really romantic kind of [ __ ] you
know get dressed cheat up have a nice
hat on go out and tie it on you know big
smokers and [ __ ]
um but i do recall like even maybe 2021
being like
i'm gonna have to keep my eye on this
[ __ ] because i could this could this
could run amok with me
you know and it took a while you know
for all my 20s i was you know drank a
lot and partied a lot but that's what
everybody does in their 20s
you know but it was until my like mid
30s i started you know
it just wasn't fun anymore i was just
doing it just
it just became a part of
in a lot of ways my everyday you know
you're always a comedy club and it's
always free to get you know and then
you're like i'm just gonna have one or
two drinks
there's no point
to me you're a great social drinker to
have one or two drinks no but i can tell
that you'll see you could lure me in oh
absolutely people who are [ __ ]
sleeping pills but there's certain
people i used to like to drink with even
though i'm not a drinker yep and i could
see
i grew up in the area you're talking
about which is what makes me walk around
even more shameful mm-hmm i was watching
mission impossible yeah and that's on
channel 20.
and there was a scene where the old show
itself
yeah yeah he walks into a guy's house to
talk to him and the first thing you did
in the 60s on television
walked into your house was you turned
around you didn't even ask no there
wasn't like leah you want a breakfast
drink no no you came here to bother me
in my office we might as well have a
drink yeah and it was a real drink and
they opened up a thing and they put ice
cubes in there they already had ice
cubes that to me was the most [ __ ]
amazing thing in the world
and then they show a bottle with no
label on it it was brown and there was
one that was white and they poured the
brown you didn't ask your host whiskey
or gin you just bought them and you said
like this and you tapped and after the
first drink so what brings it to my home
exactly well um jason tebow with austin
you in that same scene you the guy would
turn and offer you a cigarette and right
there he'd start smoking a cigarette on
television that's what men did in those
days on tv i think it still exists but
for me it's like having a bar that i go
to every day after work like i don't
have then i feel ashamed sometimes i
have that i have that that i was i grew
up in a bar me too and i saw the social
drinking and i never liked the
end result
i need to have a light the end result i
always enjoyed
the let's get a drink i remember the
first time somebody asked me to go get a
sociable i felt like a [ __ ] man yeah
i was like 16 and a half sure and he
asked me to go to ludi and those days
when somebody actually got a ludi was
let's do a loot
i got a couple loots let's split a loot
and go get a sociable and i never forget
him like drinking at the bar having a
drink at two in the afternoon
and being so excited but it was such a
letdown
like all right so we had a drink now
what right and i go home and i feel like
[ __ ]
but what saved me all those years
because there's nothing i love more than
a cold
cold
cold cold can of budweiser
that is my blood if i was when i gets up
there when i got coked up if you ask me
if i gave you an eight ball joey what
are you gonna get i'd get a case of cans
go home and put 12 in the [ __ ]
freezer yep and every time i take one
out of the freezer i put another six
pound i love my cans of butt
and i would do a line and drink a half
of that [ __ ] cold i don't know i
don't know about your fat tire which i
do like fat thai with the lemon in it i
don't know about these other ales and
all this [ __ ] i know the juice for
cocaine
but today i couldn't drink two beers
when i did coke i could drink those 24
cans in
three hours absolutely and not be hung
over the next one
not at all oh i'd be
oh
i like the taste of that beer because
like whenever i get dr i smoke and then
try to drink i don't get drunk like if
i'm already high i don't get drunk so
does it work that's because you think
you have six beers but you probably just
sip on one for like no i'm a hot i don't
like beer i'm a hard liquor guy so like
i was wondering like yeah he always
drinks the whiskey and the coke whatever
the [ __ ] i'd like makers mark make his
mark uh yeah i was a whiskey guy myself
busy and beer were really all that i
really jameson's or what did you
uh you pretty much you name it if it was
brown yeah i liked it i was down when i
drank whiskey for those two or three
years i liked it i liked how the whiskey
and the coke felt sure oh whiskey and
cocaine
a stronger irish cream at the time
and my dick would stay hard on coke with
that [ __ ] for some reason i never drank
it again i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened but i guess [ __ ] it
once i started start soaking your dick
in that [ __ ] oh my god once i started
getting hung over i have my league
that's the part where i don't like
you're not a big you
i never thought of you you know i've
known you a long time as like a big
drinker
i know you had a big coke past i do
remember some of your coke days what you
give me four lines of coke yes and
you're done you that's what i mean you
have alcohol in your house it's done
absolutely once i went to your house and
there's four lines of coke and you said
joey why don't you just hang out here
and i go what do you have to drink i got
two cases of beer i got two bottles of
whiskey
after about two hours you're like i
don't see joey drinking but he's giving
me a run see i was the opposite i would
drink
eight nine beers and then i'm like hey
this guy's got coke i'll do i was the
opposite way i would not want to do the
coke how would the beer feel now you
were drinking them like water now i can
basically go like this with your dick in
your hand yep pissing them out it's
amazing it's it really is once you have
a gram of coke in your leave you're
basically drinking to hydrate and the
body just pisses it out and i would
literally like be like at a party or
something like this and somebody would
have you know a [ __ ] gram or whatever
the [ __ ] like hey i left something for
you in the back of the toilet you know
that you know the top of the toilet put
a little kleenex over it or something
like hey i left you a couple bumps or
something
and i would [ __ ] you know i'd be so
drunk you know i got a whole bottle of
jack daniels in me and i would stumble
to the bathroom and everybody'd be like
wow that guy's probably gonna go in
there and die puke i would do a couple
bumps and i would come back out sober as
[ __ ]
and now i can start over now you know it
would erase all that you would drink and
now you could drink for two three
straight days
coke you know you go to like any any
meetings or any 12-step program or any
kind of rehabs or anything like that and
people will be like that you'll always
hear alcoholics or people that have a
drinking problem be like the minute i
found cocaine
i was a ticking time bomb because now
you're indestructible with your drinking
you know now i could you know you could
get drunk as [ __ ]
do two lines of coke and then start
drinking again you know so it's like you
know one hamburger wash the other
and then it's you know nine months later
and
you know you're selling your car
you know you suck a dick for [ __ ]
different i remember drinking [ __ ] that
i would never drink sober oh that's the
worst like drinking gin on the rocks i
was never drink that sober but when that
cocaine's in your body burning you got
to turn that fire down with alcohol
straight i'm gonna say how do you stay
so skinny
i don't know i i've just always had the
metabolism of a crack addict
because i mean were you having all just
straight liquor like shots or do you
have actual drinks no i would usually go
like jack and coke uh uh whiskey neat
was another one of my go-to's just just
put it in a glass [ __ ] face you know
what i mean no ice no i don't have time
for that [ __ ] i don't have time for
all the sugar from coke after a while
i'll be scotch meat whiskey neat
but beers that would pound beers on the
rocks absolutely [ __ ] with a can of
uh bud a bud can called
i don't even want the frosty mug take
that frosty mug and shove it up your
give me the [ __ ] can with a [ __ ]
napkin around me i want my skin to stick
to that [ __ ] can that's how i cold i
want to that's how cold when i was in
high school there was a guy named ernie
who had a bar
on 39th street by my where they burned
my mother's cemetery ernie served
anybody as long as you had cash ernie
served you and he used to give you
those beers that looked like a mug like
a like a keg oh uh uh
oh no no no the heinekens have those
little ones those little rain golds and
we would [ __ ] bang on his door at
five in the morning and you could see
him through the hole sleeping on the
pool table
and get up what he's the [ __ ] you want
we're gonna give you two more dollars
for a beer mister bernie we need two
cases who the [ __ ] is this
coco i was just here four in the morning
come on i gave you a bump he was around
the corner from where the flower guy was
yeah i know you took us there
oh really that's good i took him to
ernie's ernie's was a [ __ ] that guy
is he still alive this guy i don't
[ __ ] i don't even think her knees was
open i don't think i think it's a
spanish bar it's right
now mm-hmm
some spanish ernesto
so what morning did you wake up and you
said this is i got to do something you
know it was probably
it wasn't really just a more i think it
was like a couple weeks of just like
sick of [ __ ] being the same you know uh
you know work on a on a tv show during
football season the red zone channel
that job was up my sub lease was up
uh so i was like i get a new apartment
and i was crashing it on tripoli's couch
i was crashing to my girlfriend at the
times you know just kind of like in this
limbo
you know i was going in like the store
and the improv and the ice house every
night just because i knew i could knock
down a bunch of free booze just pissing
through cash
it just felt like groundhog's day you
know it was like the same [ __ ] day
the weather here was the same every day
everything just felt like the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i was like you know i
had opportunity
go back to my old hometown right outside
chicago
uh there's a there's a recovery house
there that i knew from when i was sober
before because i used to i was sober for
like three years
then i started drinking again i went out
for like two years and it was way worse
second time than it was yeah yeah yeah
addiction grows oh yeah it was way worse
and uh and i was just like
having thoughts like man i should just
[ __ ]
fight if i get a gun man i just [ __ ]
kill my then you start thinking about
the [ __ ] you got to throw out before you
kill yourself
you know all this [ __ ] and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
this is fixable like i just need to go
away for a while you know so i was going
to leave for not for 90 days
i was going to go this recovery house
and uh
and uh and i wound up go and so i went
up staying in my
hometown for like another three months
after being there and then so i didn't i
did one gig with rena's easy first week
i was in chicago area
because i already had it booked with
them
uh and then i started going this
recovery house and then um i didn't do
any gigs for like
two two and a half months
just
going to two to three meetings a day i
was seeing a thera addiction therapist
twice a week
and then i was working at a habitat for
humanity
cold winter cold like two degrees
without the wind just it would just it'd
be one o'clock in the afternoon sun
would be up and you'd look at a
thermometer just say two
you know like [ __ ]
uh building houses one house you just
did one house you did a whole house the
whole because i i did that in south
carolina but i was only there for like a
week so like you were there for the
entire no when i got there they were
about like half done with it and when i
left they were almost i think they they
just finished it this week because a
friend of mine just sent me a picture of
it that's what hitler told the jews it's
habitat for humanity get in there yeah
build houses some buffets and [ __ ]
everything's good i think cause i saw a
unicorn in there it looks awesome
unfucking believable
unfucking believable so you go to this
habitat for your matter they pay no
uh well i did two different things there
one i worked at this place called the
restore
where
people would donate you know you get
your kitchen redone you could donate all
you could either try to sell all your
old countertops or you could donate it
to habitat for many you get a tax
write-off then they will come pick it up
she's like a professional mover like
every day i would you know one day a
week i would do that and then we just
have they're going to these four houses
had a big-ass [ __ ] u-haul
truck that they own and then we just go
there and just haul [ __ ] out you know
that was brutal that was the worst
because it was always somebody had a
[ __ ] grand piano they built the house
around you don't know no clue how to get
through any of these doors
going on third floor you got a [ __ ]
shitty dolly you know you don't want to
not [ __ ] up their stairs and it was just
[ __ ] people wanted to get rid of and
then there's snow on the ground ice one
time we had to move a [ __ ] piano out
of a church basement the gut in his
church say leave they're like going you
guys take whatever the [ __ ] you want
just clear it all out because whatever
you don't take we're going to throw out
so going over there all day we're
[ __ ] moving all this [ __ ] and the
worst thing was this [ __ ] one of them
you know those elementary school like
they would like
stand-up pianos not a grand piano but
it'd just be like a wall when you kind
of like roll around yeah you'd think you
could roll it around but we got to go up
this [ __ ] ramp like a like a handicap
ramp going outside but it is stone
[ __ ] full of ice
i mean it's the dead of [ __ ] february
so we go out and i got a a crowbar this
other guy that i work with who's
probably got about 90 pounds on you and
you got about three inches on them
right this guy
and he's got a uh
a a hammer so we've got a hammer and a
crowbar on our hands and knees just
breaking all this ice up
so we can push this shitty [ __ ] piano
all the way up
and then and then when we got it to the
top of the driveway we had to get it up
this truck
with all this it was a nightmare it was
a nightmare so i would do that and that
would pay that paid so i got to make a
little money when i was doing that [ __ ]
and then when you would when i would
work on the house that was like
volunteering so you're just doing
drywall and a lot of painting painting
doors painting trim
just any kind of [ __ ] there was like a
contractor there to just be like you
know what do you want me to do today be
like yeah go [ __ ]
paint that wall whatever the [ __ ] you
just just do it you know just got me so
out of
it
not only was it different [ __ ] i was
doing i was around like real midwest
people nobody was constantly on their
[ __ ] cell phone no one was wrapped up
in their own [ __ ] no one's constantly
asking you about your resume you know
you were just in real life but
the weather was so different
than 82 and sunny every day that it just
felt
like i wanted to feel like myself again
really really that's really what i was
really trying to get back you know i
wanted to get some time under my belt of
not drinking every day or or five days a
week or whatever the [ __ ] but i really
just wanted to [ __ ] feel like myself
again like the guy that moved out that
was happy and hopeful and you know
gave a [ __ ] i didn't give a [ __ ] anymore
joe you know what i mean i really quit
giving it [ __ ] for about two months i
love the one thing you did you did the
smartest thing that nobody ever thinks
about
everybody always is looking when i when
i got [ __ ] up in 92 i was really bad
shape after my divorce
i kept sitting and i kept going what am
i going to do i can't i can't afford to
live i mean i was in that borderline uh
type of stuff that you can't even get
out of bed yeah that was the beginning
of this
depression but i still had enough money
to do blow every night absolutely you
know every night i went downstairs and
stole a grant from the [ __ ] landlord
i still had money to do blower you know
i cracked up my car he turned away and i
remember i said [ __ ] this and i called
my buddy go dog i'm lost i need for you
to send me money for a plane ticket
and i knew a guy and i bumped like two
thousand valiums from my time i'll be
back in a week
i knew i wasn't coming back on the
[ __ ] 20 000. oh yeah he's like take
this you can make ten thousand dollars
it was startup money yeah and that was
it he gave me two thousand and this guy
had killed somebody at some tavern he
had just got out of jail it was the lock
guy at
uh a boulder chrysler plymouth something
and i became friends and he was one of
those guys that like if i was 20
something
he was 50 but he was still he still
listened to ac dc man yeah he was a
young 50 kids no he wasn't a young 50 he
had shot heroin for 30 years of his life
then did 20 years in prison he was out
and now he had like two kids one was
like two and the other one was four he
was working as a lot man remember the
type of people i try to want to be he
when i saw him i'm like
this is what i'm gonna end up being yeah
you know i saw a lot of that too yeah
you saw a lot of that there was a lot i
mean i don't want to but you went home
yeah and sometimes the best thing to do
is go home go to your old bedroom walk
around your neighborhood walk around
your school to remember who the [ __ ] you
were dude
that is so key ain't it
nobody does that no i'm gonna go
something listen you want to get cleaned
up go back to your neighbor go to your
grammar school walk the stairs because
what's going to come back to you is what
you were thinking about at that age
that's exactly what happened of who you
wanted to be totally happy now you're
pounding nails every [ __ ] nail you
pound and cold you are now you're
thinking about your life and when you
went wrong yep it's quiet you have an
ipod on or whatever the [ __ ] you got in
your head and you're just nailing you
know if i come to you when you're
rehabbing
like whatever it is drugs a girlfriend
tree out somebody died you want to don't
get a job where you have to talk to
people
you want to think
apply for a painter's job mm-hmm you
come to work you smoke a [ __ ] tootsie
roots you put your little van halen on
you come up you tape the walls you sand
them you put the holes in and you're by
yourself
and sometimes and without the phone
and without people calling you and
saying hey how much would you charge me
for this gig yeah and without somebody
coming up to you and saying how funny
you are how come you're not getting
spots
that [ __ ] will [ __ ] wear on you dude
and it was like two years of that
that it really i mean it felt like
because it was always feels like the
same day in l.a it felt like four or
five months but then every now and then
some [ __ ] would happen where i'd be like
oh [ __ ] yeah that that's it's been like
this for two years
like nothing's gonna [ __ ] change if i
don't change something
the worst feeling in the world is to be
stuck yeah
we has
issues we spoke last night you know i've
always had issues with it you know
sometimes you're stuck in a comedy
sometimes just it's stuck and you know
when you're stuck
relationship you know when you're
starting both [ __ ] angles somebody's
gonna get pissed and stuff doesn't even
really mean bad necessarily no like for
me like though i called you last night
because i i was thinking about it i was
up to like three in the morning just
caught it's crazy that i went to college
and i you have to do that now to get a
job
but now i'm 27 and i'm just now figuring
out what i want to do
and
it's
but it's i know what i want to do but
not really
because i know
like because who knows how long
podcasting is going to last i'd love to
do this for another 40 years but
who knows what will happen
so i'm just i was just thinking last
night i don't know where i want to go
and i just
i turned my tv off and i just i folded
shirts for like two hours i think i
figured something out and
we'll see but it's just it's it's i
always knew what i wanted to do i went
to a college where if you didn't know
what you wanted to do you if you wanted
to switch majors you had to transfer
because there's like two majors
so it's just it's uh
it's a weird place for me i'm not used
to being here being stuck in careers
like you you've mentioned something
really interesting which i want to talk
to you about
before i forget sure what year did we
shoot that porno video huh
which one the one we did by the pool
where i got into the argument oh
[ __ ] i forgot about me you tripoli it
was a nose duncan
oh my god it was me and duncan that went
to that and that was at that mansion
right it was [ __ ] the other day
another crippling was that and i met
ahmed ahmed was there true i came with
duncan but
he was there duncan performed too
duncan no no no we just knew you were
performing because we were all that was
like dude dude that was like 97
98
because we all had just kind of moved
out here and started like you know
getting to know who's who and we you
were one of our favorites no i don't
know
driver he wasn't even town coordinator
yet he was driving mitzi around because
mitzi led him mitsy short who was on the
comedy store mitzi let him
use her because she wasn't driving
anymore at that point in time and mitzi
let him use her old jaguar because his
car broke down so he had mitzi's like
1986
[ __ ] jaguar for about a year maybe
two years she's just used it i don't use
it it's just collecting dust
so he was driving her like pimped out so
we thought we were bawling man it was we
had a 10 year old jaguar we were driving
to this mansion in the hills to watch
joey diaz
it was crazy that was crazy it was it
was like a girl's gone wild like that's
what they wanted
yeah but was it like a comedy special no
no no it was like a uh uh like there was
girls gone wild with comedy
sex shows yup there was girl naked
topless girls playing volleyball in the
pool ugly as [ __ ] and the girls that
were hot had clothing on they were like
fake models that like an agency sent
and i remember i kept saying [ __ ] to the
one girl and she walked away she's like
[ __ ] you or something yeah you got into
it
you are hilarious oh my god we
yeah because you knew she wanted to talk
to us but she was acting stuck up and
once i yelled and called her a dirty
[ __ ]
then i couldn't get her off me it was
hilarious once you insult a woman she
was done
she kept like coming over and the more
she drank she'd give me the evil eye
once they start giving you evil are they
going to suck your dick you know i'm
saying they give me like evil eye like
he's got me this [ __ ] i started
tormenting him and there was a little
room like a guest room there was a few
of them and i remember the guy that came
with his wife and was letting guys [ __ ]
his wife yeah there's all kinds of [ __ ]
like that
oh there was all kinds of [ __ ] like that
going on
like it was a big compound like a huge
house in the hills but it was at the top
of this hill so the pool they had a pool
house they had the regular house
and then they had all this food set up
and free everything was free food was
free drinks were free we
told them if you could lead
20 joints for you in the trailer oh yeah
there was 20 joints for me we smoked one
after the other and there was another
pound going around yep so you would that
was positive conjoints you could take
joints everything was free how long were
you there all day oh [ __ ] all day all
day eleven today it was like a giant
pool park a week and they paid me like
three four five hundred i met a med
cellar yeah and then i met set it up
yeah it was not me i think sergio love
might have been there sergio love was
there giving out that fake blow last
night i was taking this [ __ ]
i was thinking about sergio love and
sergio love used to have the worst blow
in the world
the worst absolutely you didn't even
know if it was working he would call me
the next day and ask me how it was and i
go it's great it was filled with amino
acids that's why you're getting so big
sergio those things are just protein
powders [ __ ] you
i just got okay whatever i would just
torment him
and uh so why would he buy it because
he's a [ __ ] f4 i know it's the only
[ __ ] option you had you just roll the
dice he was the last package of the
night coke yeah and it really wasn't
sometimes he gave you a good batch
sometimes i go and he'd be passed out
and i go in his pocket and like he
charged me for one but i take three you
know what i'm saying like [ __ ] like that
sergio was priceless the best was the
night he left me a a gram and a
motorcycle pouch
and when i went to the pouch a white
chick came from the shadow she's like
where sergio it was the scariest thing
in the world it was the white chick that
tried to kill herself at the comedy
store the way way before you guys time
there was a white waitress there was
very sweet and she started messing
around with the black manager that was
hanging around there a couple years ago
again oh that came back as a comic
when he came back from texas i have not
seen him in a while what black manager
and he was hanging out with your c or
somebody
and he was hanging out with this white
chick and he broke her heart
and she tried to kill herself and she
had to quit the store nobody remembers
her name i asked my wife today my wife
remembers the situation
it was kept hush hush at the store they
just got rid of it she went away
sergio bumps into at a bar and [ __ ]
hollywood takes her home [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of them
now she's in love with sergio of course
so she's stalking sergio and it was she
was in his garage hidden i opened in
those days he'd say i'll leave you the
coke in the pouch i'd have to open up
his garage and go get the coke
she was already in the garage waiting
for him guys i almost had a [ __ ]
heart attack
so the rumor was that sergio had given
the coke to freddie
the night he died her dad yeah
but the real story was that sergio
walked in as freddie was leaving freddie
was waiting for sergio but him and his
cousin went somewhere else to get the
blow so the word on the street was that
sergio's coke had killed him the little
rumor at the commie store which that
place is terrible for that [ __ ] it's
terrible
i wanted to kill him yeah ari was mad at
sergio you know ari till this day still
not cool with sergio he always says it's
the coke he's always coked up but it's
all because of freddie's soda yeah
because in the back but freddie died
from alcohol with the valiums they said
they didn't find it no that's what i'd
always heard but then just going to the
store a lot you hear those right
this place is terrible so at that time
the longest yard had just come out and i
was on the road every week and when
freddie died i was on the road i didn't
go to the funeral or the wake
and we're talking about a comic named
freddy soto and i'll never forget i was
just thinking about this last night he's
the first person to ever bring me up at
the comedy store in the o.r
good kid
sergio called me in atlanta one night i
was there
before it was this club that is not not
the improv not the place laughing skull
before laughing skull that got kid the
manager there had a different bar okay
they had two comedy clubs one there went
in toledo ohio
and i was there for the weekend i was
dying tebow dying a slow death they were
all adam sandler fans and they would see
my set and run the [ __ ] out of there
if they were going to do like the
hanukkah song oh my god i was horrible
and i went back to my hotel room and i'm
sitting there debating my life i had no
blow and the phone rings it sergio love
and i'm talking to sergio and i'm like
sir and in the middle of all the psycho
surgery i talked like i knew sergio
sergio was my buddy i lied i've known
him for very long
no problem i love him and uh
i go sergio can i talk to you about
something there's a word going on in the
street a rumor
he's like what are you talking about
listen there's a rumor that
your coke killed phrase like no i didn't
give a tango because it would be [ __ ]
up that
for years i've been buying coke from you
and the one night you get good coke
[ __ ] dies oh my god there was
silence and also we both busted out
because
i kept my [ __ ] uh i i sold it yeah
i'm like the one night you get good coke
you killed [ __ ] friends uh-huh
i remember man he used to
this might be after you probably quit
doing coke or whatever but
he used to live in this like hotel like
real almost like a high-rise sergio yes
on sunset okay that was that big black
building on sunset um kind of like east
kind of by where the radial tower is you
know that like
htla or whatever the [ __ ] it is a big
black building
uh but i guess there was condos in there
something like that he was living in
there
and yet that's where his guy his hook up
or whatever back in the day i'm not even
sure that building is still functional
but
you would
the parking garage was in the basement
of it and you had to have this passcode
you know if you were staying at the
hotel they would give you the code then
you can push the you know four numbers
and then you can go into the bottom
garage
well you would text
you know you know what's up or what's
the numbers or whatever they would know
that you were looking for code they
would just text you the
code
you would pull right into this hotel
type it in go into little basement
[ __ ] standing right there just
waiting for you for whatever you wanted
and then you would give them the you
know give money and give you coke it's
like a drive-through how do you guys
know the same dealer did you like hang
out at the store no
well no he wasn't the dealer but you
would get you could get coke from him
because of his guy but he's a comic he
was a guy
he was a comic
but anybody that does coke in l.a knows
some of the eventually you're gonna
cross and know like oh yeah i know that
dude i got some coke from that guy
or whatever i used to have this english
guy the name of english dave he's like a
pretty big like coke dealer back in the
day
uh in hollywood this is like the
late 90s early thousands and uh back at
the uh coaching horses remember that bar
yes it did something else now but back
then that was like a [ __ ] great dive
bar
you know gary shandling a lot of people
were just going there you could just
hide in the shadows it's crowded with 40
people in there you can't even move it's
a small dive bar but that's where this
guy would always set up shop
and he would always do the same gag to
anybody new that was getting coke
from them you know if you get a hookup
and you'll be like yeah this guy's cool
you you know you have to introduce him
the first time
and then he would be like hey be cool
just slide me you know give me the money
under the under the bar you know you'd
hand them 60 bucks under the bar and
then you know like there's people around
so you got to be really cool
and then he would throw it on the ground
and he'd be like you dropped your
package right there you know what i mean
everybody would look and me you would
have to pick the coke up off the floor
like a jackass
he did that to everybody and every time
you somebody knew he'd come by you'd be
like hey man get him with it you know
what i mean make him look like a [ __ ]
dick i [ __ ] die if he did that i
think i'd kill him right down the
stretch
you dropped your packy you dropped your
package i think one of the highest
nights ever on coke i was in the
coaching horses
i had gone from this is 98 i had gone
for an audition
downtown and i got lost and i ended up
in echo park
and i'm getting a flat tire i can feel
it going
god damn right there
as i'm driving the park is
i'm behind that cuban neighborhood i
didn't know it was a cuban neighborhood
then
and i'm and i'm stuck at a light and
austin i see two cop cars go they get
out and they pull their weapons and they
shoot the [ __ ] guy
this is my first six months in l.a maybe
[ __ ] i see the guy go down then the
police helicopter comes and often the
cop cars are coming up
so i turn around i get out of there and
i don't know who to call so i call
marilyn martinez uh-huh of course
goes this is what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
send over dave my husband
dave
took the tire off took it right there
and i go park up the hill there's a tire
place for five bucks got a new tire
and we got to talk and he goes have you
ever met my brother-in-law he's a cuban
dude he just got out of the chair you
want to go meet him oh yeah let's go
over there we went over the guy's like
you snort coke yeah because let me give
you an eight ball
how does this always always tell you
this was crazy
he goes if you like it come back he goes
i charge like 125 for eight balls
because all the way in echo park i take
that eight boy go home i do two bumps of
it it is out of this world oh [ __ ] it is
like the best coke i've done in 10 years
yeah i'm joined
i'm [ __ ] seeing things i got two
lines in me next thing you know i'm
[ __ ] going for bro i call josh wolf
we go over there we start pounding over
there we walk over the coaching horses
and who's in coaching horses but stan
hope and david fulton oh i'll never
forget going up to those guys and i
could not sit there like when stan hope
says to you hey dog you better go
outside that's what i remember i
remember smoking and the cigarette
was moving with my jaw like it was just
horrible i couldn't contain my miles
davis going man you're really black and
i went and i [ __ ] left there and
walked to
vista
where josh wolfe lived on that street
another car there yeah i had my car
there and i went and i put the air on
and i just pushed the seat back and i
laid back there till four in the morning
i must have had another two grams in my
pocket i didn't touch it that coke
carried me through it was that strong i
sat there [ __ ] jaw couldn't focus
couldn't jerk off couldn't get a heart
on i couldn't do dick i was so [ __ ] up
on that dude that was my last coaching i
was never really a big torture i think
in my whole life i was there tonight the
chick smacked rogan in the face
back when he the first year a news radio
he walked in there some chick went up to
him drunk and started you know because
only in this town would somebody take
television that seriously yeah they went
up to him i wasn't even standing i was
like 10 feet away he was talking to like
three girls and some girl was talking
about a cat i'll never forget that
conversation and the girl reached over
and just smacked joe and joe grabbed her
hand and was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing and she went off about news radio
that he had said something in his faith
that's when he didn't smoke pot i
thought he was going to crush her wrist
with this a lot of people don't remember
those yeah he didn't smoke pot not only
did he not smoke it he used to be so
mean to us and uptight and upbeat you
guys are gonna go smoke your dummy oh
yeah yeah smoke your dummy cigarettes
and get stupid oh my god and then he
starts smoking pot when i quit and it's
like i'm like i can't win with joe rogan
i can't win with you he we used to
torment ralphie may he used to ask us
you want to come over to the strip club
no what are you guys going to do sit
here and smoke that [ __ ] that dummy [ __ ]
your [ __ ] losers
or you don't know what you're missing
[ __ ] well now he does and now now
he's like oh you don't want to expand
your mind you've dummy i'm like i'm
always a dummy with you why i can't win
man i'm always a dummy
now what made you
when did you know you were ready to come
back
um it was a combination of things um
in august that uh uh working on writing
on that football show starts back up
okay um and you know i really wanted to
get 90 days that was my goal
i couldn't get 30
in la for [ __ ] a year
so i was like man i just want to get 90
days and then once i got to 90 days i
was like
i
started booking gigs at zanies the laugh
factory all these different clubs in
chicago i love that town so much and
it's about a 40-minute train ride from
my hometown
uh shout out to michigan city indiana
right in lake michigan it's about a
40-minute train ride so i would take the
train in the city start doing gigs but
it it didn't
i didn't want to just come back to la
start going to the comedy store start
and just start doing the same old [ __ ] i
was doing that was a big fear of mine i
was going to come back and [ __ ] was just
going to be right back to where i was
and i was i'll just lose whatever so it
really was part of like sort of like
let's say reinventing myself but feeling
like my [ __ ] self again that's where
i started gigging you know when i was 20
i started in chicago started doing stand
up there and i'm going all these new
clubs at up comedy clubs beautiful up
there i love zany's one of my favorite
clubs laugh actor was super cool to me
so i was going in there doing you know
one or two gigs a week
and i was just loving it you know and
now it's starting to turn to spring and
everybody's in a [ __ ] good mood and
everybody's so happy and nice and in the
weather's you know so i'm like i'm gonna
stick around the fourth of july
you know so i left i came back like that
maybe the 10th or 9th or 10th of july
so once i got once the spring started
coming it was getting really nice we're
almost done with that house i kind of
wanted to see that through and work
through that job
um and i was like i just randomly picked
right after the fourth of july
you know then i'll head back
um so but yeah one it really was weather
it was
weather started getting nice i had four
months i remember on
february 1st i did that gig with steve
run as easy i took the train in chicago
at two o'clock in the afternoon i got
off the train february 1st i'm walking
on michigan avenue and i'm [ __ ]
looking at my phone to see what the
temperature is and it was just straight
up zero just nothing it was dead even
zero degrees
31 mile an hour wind so it was like 22
degrees below
zero
and that whatever you didn't have
covered i like [ __ ] long johns on two
pairs of socks two pairs of gloves a hat
two scarves just a little part of your
face that maybe goggles could fit on if
that was was covered wasn't covered it
just felt like you were constantly
getting slapped by someone with a big
fat ass hand it was just like getting
slapped in the face repeatedly while
every step you would take
so when once the weather started to get
nice and i was you know now i'm doing
gigs again i hadn't done gigs in like
three months and that's the longest i've
gone and probably a decade
of not gigging you know
um you know and i had new material and i
you know i [ __ ] come you know i cut
my hair and i [ __ ] started you know
went clean shaving and all this [ __ ]
because i'm like
you know my insides i felt different on
the inside i didn't feel like that
hopeless like i want to [ __ ] put a
gun in my mouth
nothing's going to get any better i
didn't feel like that anymore but every
time i be brushing my teeth in the
morning and look at myself i still look
like the guy that used to [ __ ] want
to put a gun in his mouth
so i'm like all right i'm going to cut
my hair i'm going to shave i'm gonna
[ __ ] do all you know different things
so i just look different on the outside
because i felt different on the inside
so when i was doing that the weather got
nice i was like i'm gonna stick around
here and and do some gigs in chicago and
do some clubs that i don't usually get
to do regularly anybody was so cool
there and all the different clubs are
just like you know caught let me call
the veils in and like you know as long
as you're here man you know just hit us
up let us know what day you're in
chicago so saturday will be six months
yes sir how do you feel the truth us is
men how do you feel uh i fee oh i feel
good i feel good you know i'm not going
to say you want to go to the comedy
store have a cocktail get your dick
sucked uh that's the bottom line i'll
take the latter
of course i want to go next but you know
i can't there's just [ __ ]
you know if i if if i want things to be
different i have to do different things
that's the way i see it so if i want to
come back here
go to the comedy store when i don't have
a spot get there at eight leave it three
do that five nights a week that's what i
was doing so if i start doing that [ __ ]
again i'm gonna feel like that again i'm
not a whiner and i'm not saying this
in any negative form
part of me leaving the store
wasn't tommy
it wasn't rogan
it was
i just had to go
it wasn't helping my
addiction
i had to go one thing about the store
that if you notice about the store a lot
of people go in and they get [ __ ] up
when i first got here there was two kids
that were the nicest sweetest kids in
the world
i forgot what their [ __ ] names
doesn't really matter
and one was a door guy and we talked and
we'd smoke dope and he'd tell me about
how he got an agent and
and you know and all of a sudden next
thing you know he's teamed up with three
other [ __ ] morons and they were young
kids
and they're drinking i would get to the
store at nine you know trying to get a
fall out because my spot was at 12 30. i
was a loser i had nothing else going on
absolutely and i go to the store at nine
and i'd have my coke in my pocket
and i'd start drinking for free and once
i got off stage that's when i hit the
coke sure and i seen these three kids
just get sucked in yep and next thing
you know i asked where's the one kid and
they said you don't know what happened
he owed on heroin in the back where they
have the vip down the back i know you're
talking about it back there i know it
was larry vazio was part of that cruise
i know exactly and i seen and you know
you heard the stories of kennison you
heard you know that place was a haven
of uh death
from 80 to
94 or something and when i went in there
i'm not [ __ ] blaming the comedy store
at all but you're there and it's there
and it's 20 bucks and you're with
friends and you're having a few drinks
and you're talking about comedy and you
know what i don't really like talking to
people but you give me three lines i'll
talk to a [ __ ] homeless guy for an
hour about the history of [ __ ] the
united states or the movie slash or
whatever the [ __ ] it is you know how his
boner has stick mata yeah so
uh
uh
it did really
when i wanted to stay clean
i knew the comedy store
wasn't gonna it felt like i was going
back to the place that took me
down and away like i was like you know
what yep just something about that place
i gotta stay out there i gotta find joey
again yeah you know my my recovery i did
it in my apartment there was no money
there was no flight to jersey this last
time
this was going to bed at nine and
forcing myself to go to bed so the
addiction wouldn't wake me up at 10 30
and it did a couple nights of course
addiction will wake your [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and go don't have one drink bro
absolutely it's fine and now
i'm very fortunate that yes i smoke
marijuana
and yes i'll have i had a irish cream on
the flight the other day right i was
[ __ ] up on those stars i was hitting
this vapor pen i might as well get a
[ __ ] irish cream right i'm in an
irish cream can you can't get hooked on
ivy lady kept coming back going you want
another one i'm like no it's a bailey's
yeah yeah i know bailey's right with a
couple of different cubes in the morning
it's delicious it's like someone being
addicted to acid that's like no you're
not there's no way so that's the extent
of my drinking but uh
i'm very happy
i'm very happy for you because
i gotta tell you something you have no
idea what's coming down your road if you
stick to this and you know what team
listen if you smoke a head of drunk i'm
not going to judge you it's the devil
that got you to that dance that you
really have to focus on sure in my world
when i sat down i said listen we'd never
made me go to the atm at six o'clock and
cut and run red lights absolutely
because at eight o'clock t-bone my
insides would burn
people my insides are burned i can't
even describe that
i couldn't even think i remember my wife
talking to me about life and what's
coming out at 9 30.
i couldn't even hear the extra things
you know it was like
and eventually i just had to get up and
i'd make believe i was doing something
i'd take the atm card and run to the
rouse rock and roll routes yeah and i'd
take sixty dollars out and i go to dee's
house and pick up 60 bucks or all
compadre and pick up four packages and
once i had it in my hand that released
the anxiety now the anxiety was done i
can relate to that
and i got to deal with the 11 15 spot
it's only 8 45
i would count the minutes
count the [ __ ] minutes so i would
never do blow before you went on no i
would go home drop two packages off at
the house and take one in my in my
pocket and i put in my top thing right
here
and like you're getting three twenty you
get three separate twenty bucks whatever
i would get well okay 60 or 20.
but here's the beauty of it i would go
up there what's the biggest rumor about
me dog he leaves right after his set
yeah you know that's how you knew there
wasn't a hello
there wasn't a picture
it was basically a line of smoke where
your body used to be like get the [ __ ]
away from me it's over
joe rogan would be furious where'd joey
go ask redman where'd joey go that
[ __ ] i was the king
there was no way i wanted to hear what
you had to say about my set comedy
whatever the [ __ ] you thought i didn't
give a [ __ ] i would get that i would
pull out of the economy store
cross over to the middle lane make the
left at the house of blues yeah and pray
for that light to be yellow as i was
going down the hill because that would
give me three minutes to go in my pocket
take the ben first off before i cross
sunset i already had a dollar bill
rolled up in my hand oh yeah
and as i was driving
east on fountain i would just be doing
the 20. until by the time i got to
hollywood uh to
la brea by the time i got no i would
lived in hollywood then i would drive on
whatever what's the road fountain
fountain yeah and once i hit la brea i
throw the 20 bundle out the window i was
on fire done with it now it was a race
to get home to take a [ __ ] and to hit
the rest of that coke i would see
there was times where i in my life and
i had a coke run of about i don't know
six or seven years of like it was really
just to enhance my drinking so i was
never but i can relate to everything
you're saying i had dudes that
like
if i went to coaching horses
and i would just see
uh english dave i'd see him sitting at
the bar even if i just popped in there
for a [ __ ] afternoon pint or
something you know i [ __ ] go in there
for the budweiser whatever it doesn't
matter pop in there for a drink i see
him sitting at the end of the bar
i immediately would have to [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah that's the you see the coat
guy oh my god you would just see him
and you would have to [ __ ] your insides
would be so excited that you were gonna
do blow it's funny and i wasn't even
planning on it i didn't wasn't even
planning on seeing them and i would make
eye contact with them and i'd be like ah
now now i gotta talking to you makes me
think about
my addiction where it was in 94.95
that was one of the best parts of my
addiction because i was divorced
i was miserable i was in pain i was
alone and i was like
a squirrel what's those animals that
gather nuts yeah squirrels okay so
let's pretend for some reason i found
200 bucks
vince would give me [ __ ] an eight
ball and i would front the gram in those
days when vince came in because as long
as i had cash with the eight ball who's
the grandpa it's for jason he's getting
over lately i can see you tomorrow i
still owe vince 1800 i'm waiting to
fight i thought he would come to my
shows in denver
he still won't [ __ ] i love that kid
with all my heart but let's pretend i
already had vince figured out and it was
two in the afternoon i'd watch tv till
about four and at floor four i'd make my
liquor run that's an addict
i'd make my liquor run to uh this place
in boulder i would go to most bagels and
get a turkey sandwich with swiss cheese
or tomato and mayonnaise and salt and
pepper heavy on the pepper
and i'd go next door and i'd spend
i'd buy whatever i'd buy two six packs
of enough to get you to tomorrow two two
two six packs of fat time
in those days what was i drinking what
was the heavy [ __ ] i was drinking
i forget what the [ __ ] it was gin and
tonics maybe okay
so buy a bottle of gin and a polyatomic
and a couple lines
limes i get a couple airplane bottles of
tequila
i mean this is what i take oh yeah yeah
because i know i think you're going to a
[ __ ] bar mitzvah or something you're
like nah it's just for me serious
hilarious first 24 hours
and i would yeah i would guess
i would get the coke around nine o'clock
the eight ball and the extra gram which
would be four and a half [ __ ] grams
that that'll kill a normal per that's
what five people do yeah that's what
five people do yeah what do you think
make i was gonna ask people earlier what
do you guys think makes an addict
because some people might listen to me
like i drink eight beers
and i'm fine i think what i'm telling
you right now what we're both telling
these stories make you a [ __ ] addict
i think the obsession of the mind i
think the the the fact that
you obsess about it when it's not around
the anxiety that you discuss joey and
then i think it's like i really do
because i know people that drink
as much as i did sometimes some of them
maybe even more but their life is fine
their life is manageable they can just
do that well they have control yes and i
and i appreciate those people but
somewhere along the line
it becomes the priority drinking yeah
drinking like i used to have a
father-in-law my ex-wife's father-in-law
you know he was a
lieutenant colonel but if you call him
after seven that [ __ ] be
slurring seven nights a week right yeah
and he went to church on sundays didn't
curse in his home didn't drink then
small you know he'd drink but he hit
those [ __ ] whiskies and by seven he'd
be slurring did he have a problem with
somebody gonna tell him in his school
and his day and age there was no alcohol
problem he didn't go out and drink in a
[ __ ] car right that's it nobody knows
he was he already had all the money he
wanted he owned an insurance company
what i call him an alcoholic i'm not
sure i don't he was in the pro nobody he
never heard nobody never called you and
tortured you he never did nothing like
that well would you consider yourself
addicted to weed then because that
sounds kind of like absolutely okay
listen
you know how much of this weed gets me
high how much i'm sober already no
you're not look at me don't lie i swear
to god i think he's i would just think
so i'm telling you as your friend i'm
sober this weed
just i'm looking at this [ __ ] and i'm
when i go home i'm packing this up this
does nothing to you but destroy your
lungs this [ __ ] whack [ __ ]
this somebody this just destroys your
lungs i'm just doing it as a joke i'll
never do that again
this [ __ ] isn't lately like last two or
three months why do you think i was
smoking two vapor pens the other damn
[ __ ] tv because this [ __ ] you know my
next level is to do a line of heroin but
i won't this [ __ ] ain't doing nothing
for me i enjoy the action
i'm an action junkie the last 10 years i
did coke
you really think i enjoyed hiding in a
bathroom with no dick yeah looking at a
mirror pimp picking my [ __ ] scabs
that there's nothing in there i'd feel
[ __ ] there's a coke rock in my face see
that's awesome
like i would have no [ __ ] idea you
know you're like earlier you're like
yeah man you're you know you're a good
social drinker i'm not a big drinker but
you're the kind of guy i would like to
go out and party with and you know a lot
of my friend you know red man jason
galer a lot of people i love are like
dude you're fine man you're fine i'm
like no
you and i quit drinking together at one
you go home
i go and drink till six in the morning
by myself
i'm not fine you know what i mean maybe
the two hours you and i knocked down a
six-pack together i'm fine at 1 15
you're already thinking about i got to
get out of here because i got to catch
the liquor store before it closes it too
150 150 am if i'm at the comedy store at
150 and uh uh you know they're like hey
you want to go on and [ __ ] around with
don bears in the at the end of the night
i'm like i gotta hit this [ __ ] pink
dot i got 10 minutes to go get a 12 pack
or you know what i mean or i'm [ __ ]
how much money would you spend the night
do you think
well i was the king of i mean you know
and you know the deal dude
you really get good at spinning your
addiction into into free
i i i could i could get
i probably averaged 10 free drinks a
night just by knowing
there's a comedy story
a couple of buddies bartenders
even in 12 packs like what 15 bucks well
i'd say at the end of the night yeah
that's when he dropped ten and he drank
fifty five [ __ ] exactly 40 shots he
smoked 18 joints at the store he did
three bumps somebody offered you meth
somebody offered to take you home and
let you pet that i mean when you went to
this i mean i would there was nights i
didn't have a spot and i go i'm going
down to the store to hustle as i was
leaving i'd seen major brownie mines
throw me a 50 till friday joe you got to
follow me the atm machine that's fine
i'd follow him to the atm take a 50 go
back to the store bump into something he
goes joey i have something for you guys
chewy chewy i have a grandma blow for
you somebody would come up and go i got
a half gram of blow for you for free
then somebody go i got weed for 20 bucks
the 60 or 50 i borrowed from him so now
i just went up there with a zero i'm
home already with 30 a gram of blow and
a [ __ ] eighth of weed a 20 bag of
weed yeah that's all i needed for the
night i would go out with 20 i would
come back with 15
hammered hammered and i got three joints
in my pocket at the store tuesday
through [ __ ] saturday ten years ago
i was drunk every [ __ ] night yeah i
would wait till i do my set and then i'd
go crazy because he'd make me [ __ ]
doubles that were the size of [ __ ] uh
you know what's going on with tony
bennett you're gonna play him some time
this [ __ ] year [ __ ]
it's a beautiful day to be alive i'm
happy tebow that you uh did what you did
you're gonna see what happened thank you
buddy i hope so it's [ __ ] amazing
once you get the mentality that
man i could really go for a drink and
you're like i put work in
yeah why i tell people you could go on a
diet and count your calories go to the
gym
that'll make that [ __ ] sandwich at
night because you know leave it leave it
yeah
yeah dog
yeah i might have to eat that 500
milligram for you to take it to the next
limit because you ain't high either oh
yes
that cookie didn't do you well the wax
on the joint did and then the cookie did
what about the what about the [ __ ]
electronic puffer thing yeah that's the
the
the wack
i think
this is [ __ ] up but i'm totally
willing to believe that joey is not
stoned anymore that's good and you look
like you might be a little stoned still
this actually isn't really that like
this is halfway not kind of no this
isn't i've got a lot worse that edible
isn't bad let's eat that brownie no
thank you let's make this a [ __ ]
celebration it's like when they beat up
that guy in goodfell it's a celebration
well it's crazy because you came home
like joe we we've talked about it a lot
how many people leave and never come
back
oh yeah like that's crazy that you came
like most people don't
i mean it was always my intention to
come back but yeah i can see i can
absolutely see why people
would come here and [ __ ] lose it and
be like you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ]
these people
[ __ ] this place [ __ ] that place [ __ ]
this town
you know i mean i i could definitely
relate to that did any part of you think
you were going to stay
uh maybe five ten percent you know
once springtime rolled around and i was
loving that city so much because i do
love chicago and the clubs are so nice
and the people are so friendly
you know so many pretty girls and
everyone's so different i was kind of
like i could see myself living here man
this is a nice ass [ __ ] town well
great walk around town
great restaurants do you go to wrigley
i've always wanted to go to runway oh
yeah of course you've never been a
wrigley have you ever been to chicago
i'm
boston so i've been to fenway and i've
been to camden and then the dodgers so
that's i want to go to wrigley you're
going to hate me chicagoans i'm going to
tell you what the best meal i had
oh you're just there
chicago well i went to this place that
was cool i love this place it's easy
it's italian small marios
it's downtown i went into the first day
and got the fried diablo the shrimp with
the [ __ ] calamari and the mussels
delicious i went the next day and got
the steak aloe vesuvio delicious with a
side salad delicious water i didn't
touch the bread i'm gonna tell what the
best meal i had was
oatmeal cooked in coconut milk
what
oh my god lee did you have an italian
beef too no i didn't have an italian
beef really it's this big
it was this big one she brought i looked
at it on the menu i gotta taste that
where was it is that the same place it
was down the corner it was work it's
carlson gracie's old name but this
jujitsu master and that's where he used
to go to breakfast everybody says it's a
really good breakfast
and that's all it was with just oatmeal
cooked in coconut milk with coconut
drizzles on top and sliced banana like a
[ __ ] soldier
i'm looking to buy some coconut milk
this week and try i'm going to go online
and learn how to make that i mean
[ __ ] delicious guys if i told you i
went to chicago and the best thing i ate
was oatmeal you'd
kick him in right in the [ __ ] balls